[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash and we're
here in the studio and we are we got if
you're looking at the video if you're
looking at the the video podcast you see
a new table here or we're legit in it up
you know we got this um we got this
table here because I just got tired of
using my computer on my [ __ ] lap and
I'm tired of looking like a paraplegic
in that [ __ ] chair so anyway I'm
looking real like [ __ ] manly I'm
hunkering down and I got my [ __ ]
elbows on the table and um you know this
is it we use a couple of bags to pay for
the [ __ ] table and it's on and we got
new merch in the merch store if you're
part of the bag unit you can go you know
cop that [ __ ] we got a hoodie it's camo
we got a hoodie it's black and gold and
then we got a t-shirt that's that lets
everybody know there even the [ __ ]
bag unit now I got some dates coming up
he turned up in the head with a little
bit I got dates coming up and I got
let's see what we got here coming up
Anaheim California sandy Nez Valley
Center California Albany New York and
Hanover Maryland Huntington I'm doing 75
shows in Huntington Orvil California
Cleveland Ohio Columbus Cincinnati
Lexington anyway get your tickets at
Chris D'Elia calm and I was in I did a
bunch of shows today this past weekend
in Hamilton Windsor
st. Louis and what was the other one
Kalamazoo which that theater is awesome
the State Street Theater I think it's
called it was great on Thursday or
Friday I can't remember what day or
Thursday I think it was Thursday no it
was Friday I found out my buddy killed
himself so that was rough I'm sure if
you're a comedy fan you know about this
already a lot of people who listen to my
podcast us and a lot of other comedians
podcasts and follow a lot of other
comedians on Twitter and you follow me
on Twitter too and an Instagram and I
posted about it
Brody Steven Brody Stevens he had enough
of life and he got he checked out and he
was one of my friends and I never had a
first of all he is just he was a
hilarious guy and it sucks you know I've
never had a friend an actual friend kill
himself and it was the first time that
that happened and it's you know I've
known people that have done it and I've
known I've had close one close people
that have died but I just I you know I
saw him three or four weeks ago at a
coffee bean and we were just kind of
hanging out and it was it was cool you
know he seemed normal like nothing was
was too [ __ ] up and it took me by
surprise and you know he was I said this
on I think Instagram or Twitter but the
guy made people laugh differently like
he was just one of the funniest guys I
had ever met in my life and just totally
unique and I you know I told a story
about him on my podcast a while ago that
I tweeted out recently after he he he
died and I posted that up to let you
guys know that how how that was the
funniest night I've had at the comedy
the craziest night I had the Comedy
Store was because of him and he was on
stage and I told the story about it and
one of the episodes while back well you
know you can go look at Twitter or
whatever he's gonna look at it again but
he III don't even know he was like this
weird mix of like weird funny just so
talented like a such a such a comedian
like distilled down to it's like purest
form of where it wasn't even about the
jokes it was just about how it was just
about him being funny him stepping
onstage you know I talked about I I
think I mentioned this on the podcast
but the people who are funny already
when they walk on stage before they even
say something Brody was that you know
you know guys are like Richard Pryor was
like that bill burns like that Bobby
Lee's like that he just just step on
stage and you're just funny already he
was like that he'd step on stage the
people who didn't get it the people who
didn't really understand comedy on the
on that level would be like what's wrong
with this guy he's having a [ __ ]
mental breakdown on stage but those
people aren't they aren't advanced
comedy people like there's a certain
level of comedy that that you that you
you don't get if you aren't oh I don't
want to see a funny person but if you
just there's a level of comedy that you
know if there's a wavelength what we
talk about on this podcast but it's like
there are certain people that have that
that you aren't gonna get if you don't
have that if you weren't tapped into
that wavelength like I've had friends
come see Brody and think he's the
funniest guy I've ever seen and then
I've had people that are just like I
don't get that guy he's angry and he's
just like he's the nicest guy he was
just the nicest guy he was the sweetest
guy and he was a friend and you got to
see his stuff man just in celebration of
his life you should go look at some of
the stuff I posted or just look him up
on YouTube or something just he was just
so [ __ ] supremely funny and and it and
it for the first time for me just like
selfishly
it sucks it feels like it sucks because
like I got shortchanged or we all got
shortchanged you know the guy could have
had 30 to 40 years left of making us
laugh and it just sucks that he was in
so much pain and it sucks that all of it
all of it all of it's just it too bad
and if you if you know anybody that is
going through a rough time check in on
them because it's a real [ __ ] thing
man you know suicide is a [ __ ] I
mean I can't imagine doing it but I'm
you know the fact that there's people
out there that are thinking about doing
it is just you know I don't mean to get
so down in the beginning of this podcast
but yeah he was so [ __ ] funny man he
would get on stage and just talk about
how he parked for free at the Comedy
Store and about how on New Year's Eve he
would be like oh you know he was bombing
a little bit and he'll be he was like
I'll ruin your New Year's and just
[ __ ] god he was so funny man
some of this stuff I watched I was
laughter he died I you know after a day
after I looked at his Comedy Central
half hour which is killer dude they
reposted it it is just killer he
reposted it on Comedy Central on the
YouTube and there's this picture that's
a great picture that I posted where he's
just doing a high kick
stretching and while he brought me on
stage one time he brought me on stage
for like he would get nervous for gigs
like we did the oddball Comedy Tour
which is like 20,000 people in
attendance and he would just get nervous
and he'd be like I don't know you he
hosted it once and he brought me up for
some reason he had a mental fart and he
brought me up his Chris Hardwick and I
walked up on stage and I was looking I
was like what the [ __ ] he's like oh [ __ ]
I'm sorry you know hold on and he walked
and for 20,000 people he was just like
sorry I [ __ ] up I don't know why I
said this because Chris Hardwick was on
the show too but he was like it's Chris
D'Elia and then I walked out in front of
20,000 people I had to [ __ ] dig
myself out of that weird hole but and he
felt so bad
for like a year every time he saw me
afterwards which was a bunch I'd always
see him at the comedy store he'd be like
I'm really sorry do you hate me
and I'm like - Prodi I don't give a [ __ ]
you know but he had that mental kind of
uh that mental thing where it was like
he would have he would focus on that and
just obsess about how he thought I was
you know I I was upset about that let me
do that let me put this let me put this
there was a really funny thing that
Nikki Glaser put out on on her and on
her Instagram which was from a show
called enjoy it that I think it was
called enjoy it but it was on either I
forget what it was on HBO or Comedy
Central but this is how fun to me this
is so funny but she put this she put
this thing up on on on an Instagram
about Brody just talking about this here
with Esther
[Music]
yeah there's a party culture there so
anyway I did push it a little bit I went
to Bangkok and I went to a lady and I
pushed it to the one pushed it to the
explore the [ __ ] culture and then
this explored the [ __ ] culture and
it's messed with my mind a little bit
and I come back to America a stronger
man a clear minded man but yet
somewhat
I'm in a foreign country I'm lonely I
haven't seen my mom Daisy in a while I
matter are my friends I'm lonely I'm
just gonna accept what comes me exactly
I wish I was like you know with a girl
with the family with the child that I'm
not you will be your I always tell you
this you're still young for a man okay
my dad had me when he is 44 you're 42
mm-hmm did your father go to Bangkok and
push it to the woman I don't think he
did I did he don't wanna know have you
checked his cookies did he click on
things
that's how funny he was dude God he just
dude I mean he did he click you can
click on things anywhere not just in
Bangkok anyway dude look him up man he's
so funny and he's also the kind of guy
that would be like cuz he would be like
on on on he would be on stage and you'd
be like I've never trended on Twitter
you know like [ __ ] like that and he was
trending on Twitter when he died and
that would have [ __ ] he would have
loved that dude which is the which is
which is almost like you know it's sad
when someone dies but you but also look
when somebody commits suicide obviously
it's a really sad thing but it's their
choice and you know it's what they
wanted to do at the point at the point
in their life and it's definitely sad
but I choose to also see you know
celebrate his life because man it was a
[ __ ] it was it was awesome to it he
brought so much joy to people and he was
so so funny dude I mean just I can't say
enough about it
where's the thing about how he was doing
the this thing this made me feel so good
when he did this I didn't
this is him on stage especially my
recently and then he could say like why
cuz I'm not Chris D'Elia
[ __ ] I would go sometimes I would heckle
him like just in fun for fun there's one
time where he was like he was like he
was like I'm really high and I got to go
on this I gotta go I'm just coming so I
think I'm too high and I was like dude
he was like maybe maybe it'd be in the
back and and and because we used to do
this thing sometimes where other
comedian to do it wasn't like a thing
that just him and I did but like I would
go in the back of the room and I would
like lead him into his jokes like I
would like not heckle him but I would
like talk to him just like interview I'm
kinda in a way and because he would
forget his jokes and I loved his jokes
so I'd be like oh there's you know I
would be like well what happened didn't
something happen to you once as a child
did you get lonely and then he would go
into yeah I was lonely as a child and
then it was just [ __ ] so much fun I
loved being a part of it and I always
feel special like he made me feel
special
he made he was the Comedy Store man he
was the Comedy Store like personified he
just would do those late-night spots he
would be funny and weird and it was just
it was just it was cool man he made me
feel accepted when I was coming into the
Comedy Store and anyway recipe Stephen
Brody Stephens what a great guy and we
miss you man and I'm gonna miss you I
really well anyway that being said
thanks for listening to that didn't mean
to get anybody sad but go look him up
and because he would have liked that the
guy's too funny
yeah anyway I was in st. Louis I was in
[Music]
uh
I played 3,000 people in st. Louis which
was a lot and we were rescheduled it man
and Theo von is out there saying I'm
canceling shows I'm not canceling shows
I'm rescheduling shows and I did
reschedule it to the show and we did it
and it was sold out and it was beautiful
and by the way nobody cancels more shows
in town then [ __ ] Theo Theo so I see
you [ __ ]
I was I didn't cancel [ __ ] I reschedule
baby I don't cancel I may cancel a show
coming up but yeah so I did the st.
Louis show I did the Windsor show 5,000
people in attendance pretty [ __ ]
crazy you know we're getting up there
babies with this log cabin we're gonna
get with when we get this log cabin dude
we're gonna need to get a really big log
cabin man we're gonna need to get a
[ __ ] log we should build the first
log compound like the like a hotel just
of logs just so we could have rooms and
[ __ ] huge banquet hall you know if we
need to have a discussion we have a
banquet hall a log hotel is what we need
but yeah we're getting up there so it's
great
played 5,000 in Windsor and anyway it's
it's cool we had a good time we had a
[ __ ] good time a lot of dates and I'm
really [ __ ] sorry anyway I'm so tired
but thinking for the first time I'm
starting to feel like performing is like
I'm doing I'm traveling too much like I
feel like almost overworked but I'm
doing it for you guys and I'm doing it
also because I bought a new house and I
need to and also I'm doing a new show
I'm doing a show coming up I'm gonna be
on a show I don't know if I should say
it yeah cuz the deal isn't closed but
I'm gonna do a few episodes of this
really [ __ ] hot show that I really
like and I'm excited about it so I'm
gonna be doing that this month anyway
did you guys see the [ __ ] Kanye thing
where he was doing the I mean dude first
of all let me just say this I watched
the documentary the r.kelly thing those
six episodes of the surviving are Kelly
wow man
I cannot believe our Kelly look at this
in response to press inquiries I can
confirm the video we provided to
prosecutors yesterday includes our Kelly
clearly stating the following to the
victim
sometimes on multiple occasions give me
that 14 year-old you know what I don't
even want to say it's so I mean this is
the last one though this is kind of give
me that 14-year old booty hole Oh real
problems booty ho also that's how you
know he definitely had real problems if
you're having sex and you refer to a I
mean booty hole he was so you know what
that means he was so strictly R&B a
strict so strictly RMB that while he was
having sex he calls up an [ __ ] a
booty hole went to McDonald's after his
release you know dude he I mean left
Cook County Jail and stopped at a
McDonald's ba da ba ba but up bop ba
booty ho dude Jesus Christ there's still
people why are there people out there
that are still like he didn't do it
they're trying to [ __ ] it's a good
speed how do you how do you know how do
you know just cuz you like I believe I
can fly
how do you know he didn't do it you can
be real talented and still try to get
booty all on consensual Lee did just so
you got to be a [ __ ] special kind of
idiot to be a such a huge fan of
somebody that things are all he could
never do that
why did 80 [ __ ] people say
that they're doing it why do 80 people
say he's trying to hit a booty hole god
you know I was watching the the
surviving our Kelly thing and it goes
into they talk about like what did I
didn't know cuz I wasn't like a big R
Kelly fan I didn't know I didn't ever
think his music with all that good or
that big even like I listened to some of
his [ __ ] but like dude he played big
songs he had big songs he wrote for
Michael Jackson I didn't realize he was
that big but he did and they the first
like episode all you think I was like ah
galas and this guy's music which is like
hat you know and they get into what he
did but it I and the first thought is
anger I feel bad about it cuz when I was
watching it I was like angry but I also
felt bad I felt sad even though this may
not be right like I felt sad about the
whole situation and even for him that
like he was this [ __ ] up guy and you
know he was molested as a kid and you
know obviously what he did was horrible
and there are people who are my less
than his kids that don't do what the
[ __ ] he did but dude I mean just so
[ __ ] bad what he did obviously and
there's so many people coming out I mean
there's sick I watch this [ __ ] surviving
our Kelly just person after person after
person after person coming out saying
that he like abused them and he kept
people in he kept women in his house
locked up and would give them a bucket
to piss in and wouldn't let them out and
they had to call him if they want if he
wanted to eat that's like some [ __ ]
that's literally like a movie that where
you'd be like wow this guy's sick and
like Morgan Freeman would crack the code
and like find the guy with like a
younger white actor and then they would
go get him and and the end would be they
got get into this house and Morgan
Freeman will be there with ya like Brad
Pitt it's like seven it with like or
like it would be like a you know what it
will be will be Morgan Freeman and David
Duchovny
and the movie would be in like 1997 it's
such a movie in 1997 that would be made
and will be like yeah this this guy like
plays with 14 year old booty holes and
and like makes them piss and [ __ ] in a
bucket and and and Morgan Freeman with
like with we're hot on the trial and
then it would be David Duchovny because
he like maybe he had a few movie shots
in like the 90s it would be like we
return to me he'll be like it came it
will come out like a month after the
movie return to me with with what's that
girl's name Mimi mmm [ __ ] is that girl's
name the one from Good Will Hunting
anyway and Minnie Driver and and so and
so and that movie would be come out and
it would be like and then it would be
like David Duchovny finding r.kelly with
Morgan Freeman and and that would come
out in 1987 cuz that would be the most
1971 all-time I'd actually judge Ashley
Judd it'll be Ashley Judd we want to
lose the Ashley Judd and [ __ ] Morgan
Freeman anyway who gives a [ __ ]
whatever fixating on the night the movie
in 1997 David Duchovny was a sexy guy
huh he still is maybe I don't know how
old he is 58 years oh wow I've been seen
him in a bit dude it was so annoying how
many people said they liked
Californication when it came out that
was like the number one show that like
hot chicks would be like have you seen
Californication never saw it sure was
good I'm sure it was good David come
easy this [ __ ] I love David Duchovny um
anyway he's married to tally only right
they're cool they got their squint going
on that baby will come out and it will
be just [ __ ] I have sunglasses on
they both squint so much it's
unbelievable that the baby will come out
with [ __ ] sunglasses on the baby will
come out they're so cool the book come
out and they--but be like sob cut this
umbilical cord real quick look this cut
yeah we'd have the thing out it would
come out [ __ ] and then it would have
their sunglasses come up any be like yo
cut this umbilical cord real quick
and then you'd be like have you seen
Californication so yeah that would be a
movie [ __ ] whatever dude aye aye yeah
but so anyway the r.kelly thing which is
crazy people gig when you when somebody
like is good at music you will forgive
anything man like I'm a huge Tupac fan
it's weird because music is like tied in
to your experiences and your memories
that's what it is like you if you listen
to that song step in the name love and
it was like that was like your summer as
a 15 year old you don't want to have to
listen to that song and think about how
are Kelly was touching on 14 year olds
because that ruins your emotional
connection to your own childhood so
that's why I think these people are like
he didn't do it because they're holding
onto their [ __ ] memories and they're
like if he did it then my summer when I
was 16 year old
16 years old is tarnished and I can't
remember the the thing of what I can't
remember the way it was that's why
people [ __ ] allow Kanye to go get
away with all the [ __ ] - like yeah Magga
but also how about the fact that that
[ __ ] runaway song is so ill you ever
listened that song of the gym people
listen up [ __ ] work out hardcore
songs no dude if you listen to him an
emotional song at the gym you get much
more done for real that Sunday service
thing that he did though he really could
make a beat huh it's the whitest dance
of all time in all white
[Music]
[Applause]
he's so happy to be smiling so hard
anyway it does this thing called Sunday
service I guess every Sunday in
somewhere I don't know where but if you
can do that
a o-a o-a o-a o-a o-a kickin kickin joao
way really doesn't sound good when I do
it but I don't know a o-a o-a o-a o-a
o-a kickin kickin KO ayo ayo a Kunka
Kunka Kunka Kunka ayo ayo ayo ayo but
that's that's illis fork though it if
you can do that people will forgive
Magga you know the Liberals will be like
well yeah Magga but also got gun guy
away yeah yeah yeah yeah he's into Trump
and Trump doesn't like to you know
doesn't that isn't for helping people
and immigration and they are he's not
for you know open the borders and
keeping people in America undivided but
also gay guy Ganga Ganga aoao aoao a gig
again gay kink so whatever dude so
whatever dude you know people that that
just goes back to me saying and I've
said this that most people just don't
give a [ __ ] because your life isn't
really directly affected by it most most
people like look whether I'm for or not
not for or for the president currently
and I don't mean Trump I just mean
whoever it is if I on if I'm honest my
life doesn't change at all and and
that's most people in my at least in my
immediate circle and in my general
circle like your your your you're not
affected directly usually by whoever's
leading the country you can over a small
over a short period of time over a long
period of time if [ __ ] gets you know
changed and done but like you know so my
point is is that people don't know don't
actually most people don't actually give
a [ __ ] because you're not
directly affected by it if you are you
do and if you're a really open person
and and caring person and you do care
but it's hard to make yourself care
about this [ __ ] if you don't have to so
that's why yeah you can say Trump sucks
but also that's the kind of thing too
that if I I think it's so ill cuz
they're having so much fun I love what's
better than watching people have so much
fun but if I was there I'd be like yeah
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
I'd be the only one wearing not white
and people be like come on get into it
and I'd be like I don't know man they're
just jumping up and down and [ __ ] also
like that's the thing about music that I
just don't really give a [ __ ] about it's
like you have to bring the instruments
like that's so [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] like
you got to bring a whole big van and you
got to bring the big congos and the
[ __ ] thing and the guitars and the
piano and the end and the bass and set
it all up and then you could have fun
[ __ ] that that's why I do stand-up you
don't need [ __ ] you just need a coup
sticks my babies
you just need four walls that make a
good sound
you need a not high ceiling in some four
walls you got to bring a [ __ ] thing
to make a sound to make people dance the
second you got to bring a thing I'm out
that's the thing I don't do that [ __ ]
like skydiving I wouldn't you got a you
got a train and then jump up with a pack
on or like skiing or we talked about
this camping you got to get a tent and
all that [ __ ] nah I chill where wherever
the [ __ ] I am I'm a lot like that guy
except for the fact that he rock climbs
I'm a lock like that guy from free solo
except for he rock climbs and he needs
all that [ __ ] he needs all this [ __ ]
that you Calandra means that the but
also he doesn't he climbs solo baby he
went up the [ __ ] side of the he went
up
like this dude you see if you see the
video think he's doing it like this dude
he's like this is him holding on his
whole body with just one [ __ ] finger
and doing it that's that's that's the
way to rock climb dude you know you got
these Jason Momoa and the [ __ ] Jared
Leto doing the doing the fun one with
the colorful footholds get up there do
it actor you actor you [ __ ] actor
with a hobby dude [ __ ] hobbies man make
that [ __ ] your whole life make the thing
you love doing the most your whole life
hobby hobby asked [ __ ] actors
to picture me collecting old cameras and
taking photos and [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here
John Travolta with his flying around on
an airplane hike put a vest on with a
bunch of pockets get a stick take a
[ __ ] walk uphill dude get out of here
that I don't know why that [ __ ]
bothers me I'm such an [ __ ] dude I
mean it doesn't bother me to my core but
like I just remember seeing an article
when I was younger in like Esquire
magazine where this actor was on a TV
show and he was like and they were and
they were interviewing him about the TV
show but he really wanted to talk about
his collection of old cameras that he
takes pictures with and I thought no I
thought heck good dunk
dude he was laying I don't know what
actor was he was on something like alias
or some [ __ ] and he was just chilling
with a collection of old cameras just
like next to
and it was every picture he took with
sepia [ __ ] sepia dude everyone thinks a
picture is so much better if it's sepia
dude
sepia my ass people love sepia that
makes you feel so nostalgic you see a
picture from last week and that shit's
in sepia you're like wow I've had a
great life the [ __ ] was last week [ __ ]
that dude you make a [ __ ] old
sporting clip sepia you could have
what's his name in it David Freese and
it's still you're like wow man baseball
gonna run a long time all right abs abs
ads I mean just ABS just set abs brain -
I got a [ __ ] brain tumor man probably
all right zebra three hundred and sixty
eight dollars per year that's how much
it's been reported that the average
American is overpaying for car insurance
did you know that searching for a better
deal can take hours and most of the time
results in a bombardment of unwanted
spam calls and emails and that sucks
well no longer thanks to the zebra com
the zebra calm is the nation's leading
car insurance comparison site because
it's the only place you can compare
hundreds of policies from all the top
carriers and choose the best for you
plus they will never sell your
information to the spammers so you won't
get all those unwanted calls or emails
you just answer a few questions on a
simple fast form and they find you the
best rates and coverage in your state
TechCrunch said it's the best they said
it the best the zebra is kayak for auto
insurance it's quick it's easy just an
honest way to compare car insurance
quotes for all of the top providers all
at once this is how buying car insurance
should be are you comparing insurance
before you buy or are you not comparing
insurance before you'd buy I mean come
on
what you don't today go today and start
saving at the zebra dot-com / Congrats
that's the see the zebra dot-com
congratz spelled th ze b ra comm /
Congrats go this how I buy my stickers
online there's more than a coin flips
chance that the shoe you're looking at
is fake did you know that how can you be
sure it's real go comm is the safest way
to buy and sell authentic sneakers
online they're the largest marketplace
in the world for authentic Yeezys
Jordans and over 600,000 sneaker
listings they made the whole process
frictionless and trustworthy they do
this by only accepting sellers with the
best reputation and by verifying all
sneakers to ensure their authenticity
for buyers now they that's what if you
want to buy these and we could pay these
prices for these shoes you might as I
mean you got to make sure that they're
real right you don't wanna get ripped
off and I do it here on goat every
detail is inspected from the stitching
and the color to the size and weight
goat certifies that every pair of
sneakers on their site matches exact
factory specifications find the perfect
100% authentic sneaker at Goat calm /
Congrats that's goat calm / Congrats
plus you'll also be supporting our show
but you've got to go right now before
the sneakers you want are gone and when
you go to goat calm / Congrats spell go8
e.com / Congrats this episode of
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash app the last episode was - and the
one before that how many episodes do
they need to sponsor before you download
cash app get the cash card and start
saving money do it your babies so yeah
that's what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
you ever see a guy with the [ __ ] dude
I would never do it unless I had the
double decker keyboards dude the guy who
has the double decker keyboards is the
biggest [ __ ] of all time
imagine having to bring two keyboards
somewhere to play Wow I got a dude get
you ever see the mercy the dude with the
with the three keyboards that would be
the [ __ ] playing him one with his toes I
want to if you got for keyboards you're
the [ __ ] I don't know good dude when I
was in when I was in what do you call it
when I was in Toronto yeah heard I was
not in Toronto's in Hamilton and Windsor
dude it's so funny and I mean this [ __ ]
dude and this is like there's no
hyperbole either I'd say every I'd say
in Toronto area especially the east of
Canada every one out of every [ __ ]
seven guys is thinks they I they are
like they're like cool like in the same
way Drake is like cool like you see so
many guys that have the beards like like
the the nice trim beards like great like
Drake and and they're wearing the
[ __ ] that the the jacket with the
hood with the fluffy collar you know
with the fluffy hooded thing whatever
that is that ski jacket and it's not
even that cold but they're like yeah
betray you know they just dig IDs light
skin dark guys that are just if you're
light-skinned if you're dark if you're a
black guy but light-skinned and you live
in Toronto you're you try to look like
Drake that's just that period you can
you [ __ ] not good-looking ugly guy
and you still are like I got to get that
beard that Drake gets and get that
jacket with the fluffy hood I gotta get
that and then like by yourself when no
one's around you go just to test it out
you go oh just to like test that test it
out you know
oh yeah just to test it out how much
like you're like Drake and you're like I
could do it if the cards felt
differently I I could probably do it
Drake does but I'm kind of in my job
right now just chillin
I love how like like I listened to that
they said that what's that what what got
what on the the grammy i the grammy uh
what's the guy who what were the Grammy
nominees for best album that hip hop
what's his name Grammy what's his name I
can't remember not Santana who was it no
nominees
Nipsey Hussle that one victory rap I
tried to listen to it it's just like
it's it's just the same [ __ ] people like
like listen to the titles here let me
let me listen it no need to go to track
listings here right here whoops here we
go
tracks here we go right here we go
victory lap of course rap and word can't
say it last time I checked young and
word dedication blue laces to hustle and
motivate status symbol but they're all
like I tried listening to it it was kind
of like all the same song maybe I'm just
an idiot I don't know just people were
talking about how good that album was
God have you guys seen that you know
what one of my faith dude you know what
actually I want to do first of all you
got to look up this one video this is my
favorite video I never laughed so hard
at a blooper then this one here this
tech TV blooper right here okay dude I
never left a one-of-a dude I never left
I never left harder at a blooper video
than this one oh my god dude okay is
this older man I've shown you this right
this older man
it's called tech TV blooper his older
man and this guy is well I'll just play
it this is a one-of-a-kind piece there's
no other one like this particular one in
the world and you can see the tracks go
this way
and it's really cool because it records
much more accurately but oh my god oh my
god dude
okay he's literally just holding it
nothing's happening and it just explodes
he didn't drop it and then it's a
one-of-a-kind
like this particular one in the world
and you can see the tracks go this way
and it's really cool because it records
much more accurately
oh my god dude guy doesn't know what to
say
he goes oh he was gonna say [ __ ] but
then didn't because you want to swear
[ __ ] like the second wave of oh just
overwhelmed when he was like I guess I
got to say [ __ ] oh my god oh my god this
he says oh my god - which is it's really
cool because it records much more
accurately but oh [ __ ] oh my god can't
be good now that's so funny
are you done with that one it just
exploded huh yeah you're done with it
that one and then the [ __ ] ladder the
QVC ladder won't forget it to it forget
it dude I don't know which one I like
better I don't know which one I like
better dude this one oh my god the
home-shopping ladder blooper this one
right here first of all this is the
dumbest the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen in my life it's a ladder that
[ __ ] will put it on the video podcast
but it goes up and you can make it go
across and then down for no reason for
no [ __ ] reason alright so he's
showing how to do it and he's crawling
across the ladder it's a very easy but
equation to operate you just push the
buttons in right here on on the two
sides the two little buttons and all you
do is push them in and that will release
it and went right here push the button
and that releases it and then after you
let go it locks perfectly in place so
really you're all set and this is tough
and this is tough alright any by the way
guys who as or as tall as the woman
they're talking to are the are the most
hilarious guys like it doesn't matter
how tall you are if you are as tall as
the woman you're talking to you are a
savage now the woman can be 6 - I'm 6 -
if the woman 6 - and I'm talking to 6 -
a woman I
therefore submit now that happens way
less because I'm 62 and not many women
are 62 but if you're as tall as the
woman you're talking to you are a submit
and you're drawing the [ __ ] up and
that's just how it is now her [ __ ] is
going like this because it's dry
congratulations but that's how it is
okay
now this guy is trying to show this girl
how the latter works because he's a
representative of the ladder and it is
her job to be on the show and have this
guy on and tried sell his letters
now she is wearing for some reason a
goddamn gown now that's [ __ ] stupid
because she looks ridiculous she
couldn't look more Mormon and he is as
tall as her therefore he is asked a
[ __ ] now he locks it up I go back a
little bit look I couldn't look more
like he sings in that [ __ ] what is
that were they the four seasons sure is
that the four seasons no it's one fire
one fire it's all good but one fire
Frankie Valli and the [ __ ]
degenerates or some [ __ ] you know the
generates is probably wood that does
definitely a group the four seasons okay
Frankie Valli example so he now he tried
to crawl across right there's no [ __ ]
idea dude she has absolutely zero idea
right right and he's crawling across
dude you don't understand this ladder
how do I describe it for the audio
listeners so the ladder it it's it's a
bridge you crawl up it and then you
crawl across it and then I guess down
and he's like say you have to go but you
could just use a regular ladder for the
[ __ ]
so you have a you know you have to get
up in the wall - you have to get up on
the wall I said oh you mean what a
regular ladder does okay right the best
I never realize how awesome and loaded
her right is you know you have to get up
on the wall or - oh boy oh dude the
casualness of höwedes listen just walk
right up okay so he's now he's walking
up Wow
so [ __ ] how he looks when he's walking
right up okay okay now what happened
right there was he buckled a little bit
like about I'd say 10 inches and he
almost fell and he's crawling across it
which means if it did buckle his face
would go directly into the ground okay
so Frankie Valli Frankie Valli he's
talking - oh my god all right so all
right so so now atlanna neat and then
he's so [ __ ] goddamn scared but he
says it's in aus locked in place cuz he
has to cuz he has to coz he's trying to
sell these he has no choice but to now
that's the that's the best dude there's
nothing funnier than that the guy has to
sell these ladders because he's a
representative the ladder I don't know
if he owns a letter or what but he's
representative he needs to make money
dude so he goes to crawl across it he
said now it's completely safe it's
locked in place and then it falls a
little bit scaring everyone and then he
says see now it's locked in place he has
no choice otherwise he will sell 0 the
only hope that he has to sell any is to
crawl across and and nothing bad have
had nothing bad happens but as you can
see it does not say okay so really so he
goes
[Music]
his chin goes directly into the ground
and he's actually I didn't have it
locked yeah no [ __ ] also don't need it
get a regular ladder dude if you need to
go to this and then it cuts immediately
to the stock footage of the ladder which
is the best the guy was on standby it
cuts so quickly the guy was not he's
like he hit into me because he knew
frankie valli was gonna hit it dude when
he said actually I didn't have it locked
[Music]
okay so really you have to lock it
once you lock it you're okay but it is
very safe to operator
dude the the steam coming out of like
the wind out of it at the end that last
right here
it is very safe to operate just so
defeated so defeated it is very safe to
operate new just people hanging up
across the country
you have to loss it yeah once you lock
it you're okay but you got a look at
this video look at the different the
different [ __ ] things you can do what
the ladder is just so hilarious look at
this one dude why would you do that why
would you do that
they made it 1-1 where you can just it
go it's like up down like a zigzag
across the ground what the [ __ ] would
you want to do that with a ladder what
would you do that except hurt yourself
and it's $200 $200 for chipped teeth Wow
3.3 million when I first saw that video
I was had no hits do it wow we were
laughing hard me my brother I mean look
at the things that come up with QVC
ladder fall death QVC knife how about
the [ __ ] 100 got me that one the
samurai one you know that one you busy
the the fact the way they have to save
face is so funny dude
cuz they can't be like oh you know they
got to be like oh it get me here we go
why are these guys screaming always
11:01 get your mic 1101 1816 is the item
number on this one 1101 1816 is the item
number on this one and the nice thing
about these practice guitar the blade
comes off and stabs his abdomen that
hurt big-time a piece of that just the
tip just got me O'Dell
[Laughter]
bro you stabbed yourself I love how
these guys always try to minimize it
dude you why can't you just be hurt
Oh a piece of that just got me stabbed
himself yet O'Dell - just got me the guy
needs emergency surgery the guy I mean
he's like you didn't hit his eye
dude when when the guy when Odell
somebody who commented working on by one
of those tables O'Dell afterwards uh we
might need to get like just the craft
service guy we may need to get emergency
surgery like he's just a [ __ ] what's
his name Mike judge character [ __ ] is so
funny dude but but let's look up the
[ __ ] one that I've been meaning to
look this one up it's for so long Jim
Rome Jim Everett one this is so this is
where the coin we coined I think my
brother and I coined probably submit was
such a big term in my brother's life and
it had been brewing and bubbling but
this a [ __ ] [ __ ] came like this is what
one of the first seeds of my brother and
I starting to call everything so [ __ ]
Jim Rome that's not what everyone Jim
Rome Jim Rome here we go versus Chris
Evert first of all so such bad footage
like dude how come in the night [ __ ] do
you ever see old footage of [ __ ] you're
like how did I ever watch TV it looks at
you're watching without the [ __ ]
glasses on it's so bad
HD is everything like how did you use to
jerk off the porn on VHS the [ __ ] looks
like [ __ ] what do you call it a like
the product like the [ __ ] techno bowl
or some [ __ ] tech mobile techno tech
mobile tech mobile yeah so so Jim Rome
is interviewing Jim Everett and he calls
him keeps his good Chris Evert was a
female tennis player and Jim Rome would
say on his program that Jim Everett he
would call Chris Evert because he
thought he played like a [ __ ] I guess
weaker than he normally does weaker than
a football though should play like if he
was doing the sexist like yeah you play
like a girl thing so Jim Everett now
finally gets on his show and calls him
out and it's so fun he's now playing for
that team I mean Jim Rome it's these
short frankie valli type guys that are
the most submit guys in the world just
how he says check that chris evert like
just so heated so first of all so shitty
to invite a guy on your show just to be
shitty to him so bad journalism like be
a little bit more cagey and then he was
coming he knew it was coming Jim Everett
knew was coming so hard look
you think you know what anything I guess
it's you know what they knew it was
common Oh [ __ ] what a [ __ ] two years
actually Chris and then again twist the
knife oh it got me right there twisted
it I called him Chris again how nerve
saneras years bolt these guys some
nervous Jim Rome so nervous because Jim
everich could beat the [ __ ] out of him
and Jim Everett so nervous because he's
in an interview and doesn't want to be
exposed
they have nervous smile so hard their
biggest along the way Jim ceased being
Jimmy became Chris insecure let me tell
you a little secret that we're sitting
here right now
not secret that's the best when cuz
because Jim Rome is trying to let go
back and be like well already did twice
I don't have to do this call you out on
your threat thing so that should count
and you should be beating me up already
but you're not going to and I'm calling
you out on that [ __ ] but Jim everyone
five-minute segments got so nervous or
five segments show five minute segment
or five seconds so every both of them
are so nervous right now it's so funny
good what we do well we do and he's
smiling
did I just before we even play it the
beat Jim Rome takes before he decides to
call him Chris again is the most unreal
beat ever taken okay Chris
the sound goes it tosses the table up
and just tosses him down the way Jim
Rome gets up to his savage this little
[ __ ] dude that's the kind of [ __ ] you
get knocked the [ __ ] out if you do that
Chris Jim Rome is a [ __ ] for that
though no I'm sorry Jim ever it's a
[ __ ] for that gotta rest
oh this that's fake that parts fake oh
wait is that really what that is no cuz
they turn the mic off I'll tell you what
dude if somebody [ __ ] called me out
on that [ __ ] oh I'd love to call him gee
I'd love to call him Chris again come on
Chris
let's do this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah dude
he got fair warning to me hey did this
is a doctor this is dr. Chris
[Music]
chance that why did they do that she's
not really no that's the best you call
me Chris Evert to my facial murder Lee I
already did it twice ah man that's so
funny the whole thing is so [ __ ]
alright whatever you want to do the all
right the mist the missed connections
we're kind of where we going to four
missed connections now now we're going
all the way to where Birmingham
Birmingham Alabama we did Miami we
thought it only right to do Birmingham
Alabama because we did a funky cool a
fun place and now we're doing the place
where why would you be there gasp
Christmas tree and then gasps thing
highway 280 looking for someone on
highway 280 that sells a weed please
call I mean
it's 2019 you're on a highway this is
the most [ __ ] Birmingham [ __ ] of all
time you're on a highway and you want
weed and you decide to use your phone
your smartphone to go on Craigslist and
post that you'd like weed there's
already definitely craigslist ads for
weed if you need weed this guy's such an
idiot do not contact me once illicit
services or offers sir Birmingham next
oh boy well like this title this title
is hunting my plumber ok seaville
looking for the plumber who work on my
septic
it was too small and you tried to
stretch it but it was too so hey man be
better at being symbolic get better with
your [ __ ] what do you call it uh
what'd he call him similes now what
metaphors yeah make your metaphors
better at looking for the plumber who
work on my septic opening it was too
small and you try to stretch it but it
was too soft to finish the job or anyone
else that knows anything about how to
open it up and other activities that you
want to get huh
so had such a bad childhood God had such
a bad childhood and didn't pass English
like the not even English English the
[ __ ] part where you'd learn about
symbolism didn't pass that part either
do not contact me with unsolicited
services or offers hunting my plumber
you know all right here we go ah the
title of this one is need someone with
chlamydia or gonorrhea oh trying to get
a sample of either of these two for an
experiment don't want to pay for the
online samples so let me know if you can
help what the [ __ ] does that mean
you know you're trying to [ __ ] who this
is like how like a Batman villain starts
do not contact me with unsolicited
services office so he just wants a guy
he wants like a blood sample or what
what the [ __ ] dude
hey Birmingham what's going on hey
Birmingham get rid of this guy that's
gross dude I miss having I missed having
skin party for females or couples plenty
of ice cream
dad Chris have read hey there i'm bored
hey there i'm a bored to death 49 year
old white guy looking for like-minded
women or couples to join me at the party
for some skin fun dude this guy spell
skin sk8 I ended you're not hiding it
from the law what are you hiding it from
the administrators them we get it man
you already in trouble if interested
here's where you can find me and then
the address or the number do not contact
me unsolicited services are offers duty
doesn't this come oh there we go skin
party hey there I'm a bored to death 49
year old white guy looking for
like-minded women or couples to join me
at the party for some skin fun there's
some weirdos out there huh alright a
simple day late nothing more so many
[ __ ] hashtags and so many [ __ ]
asterisks in this [ __ ] thing for no
reason
ring the doorbell come inside join me
for a shot and let's just start kissing
and getting things going
why complicated lol it's just a play
date we aren't talking about dating or
marriage I don't get time off work much
so I need to enjoy myself tonight
message my something GML I don't know
what that is it's okay oh hey look at
this it's okay to contact this poster
with services or other commercial
interests this guy's looking to get a
deal to another one one more two more m4
couple white male looking to meet up
with a couple for some fun activities I
love plus-size women let me eat your
girl I the guy really [ __ ] went for
it at the end oh by the way let me eat
your girl out check that Chris have red
but you know what I'm here and you know
what let me tell you a little secret you
know we're we're in on a TV show and we
you might want to if you want to go to
commercial break but I guarantee you
don't ask me to eat my girl out one more
time already did it twice well I bet you
don't do it again okay bet I do
let me your girl out I mean do it do not
contact me unsolicited River white male
looking for to meet up with a couple for
some fun activities I love to outside
women let me let me your girl out with
an exclamation point
wow man Birmingham knows how to party
huh I psyched that song we like to party
by the Vengaboys wow Vengaboys is the
most homosexual music of all time Venga
bus so french or it's so [ __ ] goddamn
French whether in a bus and they're
dancing this would be so not fun dude
[Music]
guess if they're in tight shirts oh not
the guys gets if they're in tight shirts
or not that should go over their jeans
more Wow
also during the Vengaboys and I only see
the chicks not even seeing well so vague
so bad so [ __ ] fringe dude the cliche
[ __ ] that they're just saying
happiness is right around the corner
what
how bad is this goddamn song the
vagueness it pisses okay so you like to
party oh it's their Spanish same thing
in French you know
[Music]
exactly the same French and Spanish
by the way would be French did this
video without knowing about the video
they make the same video right here so
I'm a cliche things I'd like to party
okay they've got something to tell us
okay
okay news so what is it already so you
got to tell us that you can afford all
right get ready for all right we'll get
to it what's up okay dude okay so much
build-up it's a minute into the song is
that what they're to tell us happiness
is run a corner okay
so yup they're you there for us [ __ ] you
dude you didn't tell me [ __ ] dude you're
like some [ __ ] Instagram chick with
the fit T alright dude I'm out of here
[Music]
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market download
the crystally app wasn't able to get up
there today I'll go live for you guys in
a little bit but I wasn't able to get on
there today because they changed a lap
around support to show by buying merch
at store crystal a comma got a new bag
unit shirts and hoodies and hoodies uh
subscribe to the YouTube channel
subscribe rate review the show to me by
using the handle hi congrats pod or by
using the hashtag congratulations pod
video episodes go up a day after the
audio podcast you can check my episode
of comedians of the world non-stop on
what do you call it Netflix and then you
can watch man on fire incorrigible it'll
go but my black comic on Comedy Central
app and that's it and I got a I'm gonna
be doing a show soon you I'm gonna be
shooting something certainly but you
know next week but I'm doing anyway
thanks for listening my babies okay take
care
[Music]